[Musique]
prendre soin documentaire réalisé par
Bertrand Agen Muller et co-écrit avec
Bernard Benatar une immersion vous venez
de le voir dans le quotidien de trois
soignants au coeur d'unité Alzheimer de
maisons de retraite et loin des
représentations habituelles ce film nous
a livré un regard d'une formidable
humanité sur la relation qui s'installe
jour après jour entre soignants et
résident au sein de ces unités un an
après l'affaire hors pa l'occasion pour
nous maintenant dans ce débat doc de
débattre de la situation des résidents
et du personnel soignant dans les EHPAD
avec nos invités présents sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui Caroline chat pour commencer
bienvenue vous êtes député à les filles
de Meurthe-et-Moselle vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale ancienne
aide-soignante c'est un métier que vous
avez exercé pendant 9 ans en
Meurthe-et-Moselle justement et vous
êtes également co-auteur d'un rapport
d'une mission d'information
parlementaire sur les EHPAD rendus en
mars
de 18 un rapport que vous avez réalisé
avec vous moniky Bora bienvenue à vous
vous êtes député renaissance de la
Haute-Garonne et puis enfin avec nous
Elise Richard bienvenue à vous vous êtes
journaliste réalisatrice indépendante et
auteur de Cesson de maltraiter nos vieux
c'est un ouvrage publié aux éditions du
Rocher ou après trois ans d'une enquête
fouillée et bien vous avez livré votre
éclairage sur la situation de l'aide aux
personnes âgées dans notre pays et pas
seulement d'ailleurs dans les EHPAD donc
il va être question dans cette émission
Caroline Fiat ce documentaire il rend
d'abord hommage au personnel soignants
qui officie dans ces EHPAD est plus
particulièrement dans ces unités
Alzheimer qui font partie d'un certain
nombre de ces EHPAD j'imagine que vous
avez
ressenti des choses toutes particulières
vous exercez encore ce métier vous
l'avez exercé en tout cas à plein temps
pendant 9 vous êtes reconnu dans les
propos tenus par les
personnels soignants qui témoignent dans
ce film alors reconnu oui et non sur
lesquelles je partageais d'autres un peu
moins
juste enfin voilà c'est on est bien dans
une unité de vie protégée ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement UVP quand on vous
dit vos personnes en UVP c'est une unité
de vie protégée dites unité Alzheimer ou
vous n'avez que 14 chambres dans cette
unité et je tiens à le préciser parce
que du coup ces unités ont un ratio un
peu plus élevé que les autres
ailes parfois dans dans les EHPAD
mais j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce
documentaire en me disant que bon si
tout les unités du protéger était comme
ça ce serait peut-être déjà un bon début
mais c'est ce qu'on veut noter les
spectateurs c'est pas forcément la vraie
vie celle que vous avez vécu à
l'intérieur même de ces unités moi
personnellement j'ai travaillé dans un
EHPAD lucratif on était trois la nuit
pour 180 résidents moi j'avais deux
unités de vie protégées et un couloir
soit palliatif donc autant vous dire que
j'avais pas le temps de border mes
résidents comme on peut le voir à la fin
du documentaire mais ça existe
heureusement tous les EHPAD ne se
ressemblent pas
je pense que pour les collègues qui ont
regardé ce documentaire certains vont
apprécier certains vont peut-être avoir
un petit pincement au coeur en disant
mais qu'est-ce que j'aimerais avoir le
temps de m'occuper autant de mes
résidents on va écouter un premier
extrait du film c'est un lait de
soignant qui nous explique pourquoi il
fait ce métier
on peut pas le faire sur le fait pas
avec notre cœur
si on le fait avec notre tête ça marche
pas
ça veut dire qu'on le fait on attend
d'avoir l'argent à la fin du mois et on
rentre chez nous et c'est pas possible
on gagne pas de l'argent avec ce métier
qui témoigne des motivations qui l'ont
amené à faire ce métier il est pas
question d'argent dans l'esprit de cette
femme qui s'exprime dans cet extrait
c'est aussi ce que vous avez constaté au
gré des visites des établissements que
vous avez pu faire notamment dans le
cadre de la mission parlementaire dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure oui je pense
que ce qu'on voit dans ce documentaire
c'est justement des personnes qui sont
là et qui ne ressemblent pas à celle qui
était là il y a quelques années quand on
a créé les maisons de retraite et que
les organisations n'ont pas suivi
justement le fait que aujourd'hui 90%
des personnes qui sont dans les EHPAD
sont des personnes qui ont des troubles
du comportement on l'a vu à quel point
il y avait des problèmes aussi de temps
en temps d'agressivité et on voit donc
que les organisations qui étaient mis en
place il y a quelques années ne
correspondent plus du tout à la réalité
des choses et d'autre part on voit en
même temps à quel point même si en effet
on retrouve pas le même taux
d'encadrement de personnes dans tous les
EHPAD aujourd'hui malheureusement
on voit bien à quel point le relationnel
dans le dans le traitement même et dans
l'assistance de ces personnes est
importante et qui dit relationnel dit
évidemment un nombre de personnes de
personnel suffisant pour assurer ce
relationnel
il y a eu ce livre bien sûr les
fossoyeurs de notre confrère Victor
Castanet qui a été une véritable bombe
on peut le dire puisque il a révélé
moult maltraitance dans les
établissements ORPEA qui sont des
établissements privés il existe
aujourd'hui
7353 et pas dans 95 départements en
France en moyenne c'est une place pour
10 personnes de plus de 75 ans dans
notre pays 44,5% de ces structures sont
publiques
31% de ces structures sont associatives
et 24% de ces structures sont privées
vous avez travaillé dans un
établissement privé et lorsqu'on parle
d'Orpea on parle également d'un
établissement privé il y a une très
forte disparité entre ces établissements
sur le coup de ces établissements sur le
nombre de personnes soignants présents
dans ces établissements où se situe
d'après vous et d'après votre propre
enquête les principaux problèmes
lorsqu'on parle de la situation du
personnel soignant et des résidents on
n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
en fait le principal problème très
clairement il est dans le dans le nom
justement de personnel
auprès des résidents à la fois tout
personnel confondu c'est-à-dire voilà
l'ensemble de personnels et notamment le
personnel soignant ça veut dire
infirmier aide-soignant principalement
puisque globalement sans rentrer trop
dans le détail et c'est ce que disait
justement
les deux députés dans leur rapport on
est aujourd'hui à 30
personnels soignants pour s'en résident
alors qu'il en faudrait le double pour
qu'on ait justement un accompagnement
idéal
en tout cas
[Musique]
vraiment souhaitable dans les
établissements ça c'est sur le personnel
soignant et dans le personnel
je crois plus important dans les
établissements publics que dans les
établissements privés un paradoxalement
et contrairement à ce que croit beaucoup
de personnes est-ce qu'on pourrait
penser qu'en mettant en fait son parent
en maison de retraite privée en payant
plus cher on pourrait avoir un meilleur
accompagnement et en fait c'est pas
forcément le cas et c'est même souvent
l'inverse puisque les chiffres prouvent
qu'il y a moins de personnels dans les
établissements privés lucratifs que dans
les établissements publics et ça c'est
vrai que c'est très étonnant alors le
point central selon vous c'est ce fameux
ratio finalement personnel soignant
résilient et c'est effectivement le
point central de votre rapport commun
d'ailleurs vous demandez un ratio tout
simplement entre personnels soignants et
résident et sera sous une n’existe pas
en tant que tel aujourd'hui et c'est
c'est là que résume de peut-être la clé
pour améliorer les choses dans ces
établissements
un ratio de
06 soignants aux chevilles du résident
pour un résident c'est le ratio minimal
c'est le ratio pour freiner la
maltraitance institutionnelle
au Pays-Bas c'est un deux je crois pour
un et au Danemark 1 4 pour 1 nous un 06
mais c'est vraiment
l'idéal j'entends que doublé le nombre
de personnels ça a déjà
un coût et là mais au moins on freine la
maltraitance institutionnelle mais c'est
un ratio minimal c'est à dire qu'on peut
largement largement l'améliorer mais en
dessous on est dans la maltraitance
alors les ratios et les mathématiques
mais l'orphelins on parle de évidemment
d'un sujet un peu plus humain ça veut
dire que avec le ratio actuel si au
moyen que vous avez cité
un personnel soignant un aide-soignant
une infirmière combien de temps
d'impatient par jour en moyenne alors
avec le ratio actuel on est à 25 minutes
25 minutes sur 24 heures par résident 25
minutes par jour sur 24 heures et avec
le ratio que on proposait on passait à
1h30
de soins par jour par résident enfin
vous savez une toilette protocolaire
c'est entre 20 et 30 minutes une aide au
repas c'est 10 minutes il y a trois
repas
changement de protection tout le long de
la journée
ou alors accompagné à personne aux
toilettes c'est une demi-heure stop ça y
est j'ai fini mes soins j'ai pris mon
1h30 pour la personne donc il y a pas
d'activité il y a pas enfin la
discussion peut la faire pendant la
toilette
comme on a vu dans ce film
donc là dites-vous que on a beaucoup
moins actuellement et donc une toilette
protocolaire généralement c'est en moins
de 5 minutes
j'ai fait le même constat je l'ai dit
vous étiez d'accord sur ce point
il faut de monter ce ratio
je croyais en effet ce que
nous disait
Caroline le problème si vous voulez
c'est que
au-delà de
du nombre de personnes nécessaires il y
a toute une organisation et quand on a
dit en effet on n'a pas suffisamment de
personnes moi ça m'a sauté aux yeux
réellement et on a on a été très
contesté on a été contesté par tout le
monde on a été contesté par les
établissements et les établissements
privés en particulier
me souviens d'une émission de télé
d'ailleurs on a été contesté
pourquoi ils étaient les arguments qu'on
vous avançait
le nombre de personnes nécessaires et
que absolument faux et donc à partir de
là si vous voulez les choses se sont
modifiées maintenant il a fallu 5 ans
quand même c'est beaucoup tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire en effet vraiment
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire oui
il faut augmenter le personnel le seul
problème qu'on dit maintenant qu'on
entend maintenant c'est de dire ah oui
mais on peut pas recruter parce que
personne ne veut venir et donc là on est
dans un cercle vicieux duquel il faut
absolument sortir et il faut en effet
que dans la loi et et là moi je serai la
première à le défendre même si je suis
pas attitude je suis pas la seule il
faudra qu'il y ait en effet comme d'un
service comme dans certains servir sur
l'Hospitalier d'ailleurs un nombre
minimum de personnes et moi je vais je
précise où je vais des personnes pour
les raisons que je vous ai donné on a
plus les mêmes personnes aujourd'hui
dans les EHPAD qu'on avait il y a il de
10 ans où il y a même moins et donc
c'est nécessaire qu'est-ce qui bloque
selon vous sur sur ce fameux ratio à
mettre en place
Brigitte bourguignon qui était ministre
pendant un certain temps de sur ces
sujets étaient hostiles plutôt à ce
ratio considérant que c'était des
dépenses qui étaient pas toujours
justifiées et puis Monique Bora vient de
nous dire il y a pas de personnel le
projet de loi de finance de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 prévoit
le recrutement de
soignants pour les établissements et
Emmanuel Macron le chef de l’état on a
promis de 50000 sur l'ensemble de son
deuxième quinquennat c'est possible
selon vous qu'est-ce qui bloque là ce
chiffre là
c'est c'est vraiment ridicule en fait
par rapport aux besoins
en fait il faudrait
globalement rien que dans les EHPAD
recrutés quasiment 150000 en fait
personnels pour que ce soit à peu près
vivable et enfin souhaitable
pénurie de personnel c'est vrai alors
c'est vrai que le problème en effet
c'est qu'il y a une crise de vocation
entre guillemets ou de recrutement parce
que les conditions de travail sont très
dégradées et donc c'est un peu le
serpent qui se mange la queue comme le
disait madame ibora parce que en effet
vu qu'il y a très peu de personnels pas
assez personnels il y a beaucoup
d'absentéisme donc les conditions de
travail sont dégradées donc forcément ça
encourage pas le personnel à vouloir
travailler dans ces établissements le
problème c'est que si on recrute pas on
n'arrivera pas à tirer
mais ce qui en fait ce qui est moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé justement dans ce
documentaire c'est de montrer justement
et parce que ça donnait la parole
justement aux résidents et on voit qu'en
fait la plupart ont besoin de parler
énormément ils ont besoin de temps
d'écoute d'accompagnement évidemment
de toilettes etc mais aussi de temps des
changes et que s'il y a pas de
suffisamment de personnel c'est pas
possible d'avoir ce temps d'échange de
qualité et moi la plupart des soignants
que j'avais rencontrés au cours de mon
enquête me le disait en fait qui vivait
dans un sentiment de frustration
permanent c'est ça qui revenait sans
cesse le sentiment voilà de ne pas
pouvoir faire son travail correctement
de ne pas avoir les moyens en fait
d'effectuer leurs tâches et ce pourquoi
voilà ils étaient embauchés de manière
suffisante et donc ça généré de la
frustration
juste parce que là le ratio on avait
calculé ça faisait 210000 personnes
embauchées juste parce que que les gens
sachent il y a 180 000 infirmiers
diplômés d'état qui ont changé de
profession qui ont quitté la profession
on n'arrive pas à voir le nombre d'aide
soignants mais à peu de choses près je
pense qu'on est dans la même donc en
nombre de soignants dans notre pays pour
venir on les a même sans former on a des
gens qui ont quitté la profession ce
qu'on leur demandait de maltraiter
plutôt que de soigner leur résident et
moi ce que je peux vous dire avant
d'être élu député j'avais été licencié
et j'hésite je savais pas si je voulais
recommencer si j'étais élu député
réellement si demain vous dites aux gens
vous allez avoir un ratio vous allez
avoir le temps de faire vos soins le
temps de répondre aux personnes il
reviendront et il y aura pas de crise de
nos métiers parce que on attend que ça
faire correctement notre métier par
contre dire aux gens l'année prochaine
on embauche 3000 personnes et vous serez
dans la maltraitance c'est sûr que ça
donne pas envie je veux dire
au-delà du niveau quantitatif du nombre
de personnes il faut bien entendu aussi
travailler sur globalement tous les
métiers du soin qui sont d'ailleurs la
plupart du temps des métiers féminins
et on doit vraiment valoriser ces
métiers pas seulement d'ailleurs au
niveau du salaire bien que ce soit quand
même important et c'est ce qu'on a
commencé à faire ce que jamais personne
n'avait fait il faut bien le dire mais
au-delà de ça il faut donner un sens et
il faut donner du temps de présence en
effet à ces personnes et il faut donner
une formation parce qu'actuellement
encore une fois je m'excuse je répète ça
parce que ça me paraît tout à fait
important pour comprendre les besoins
que nous avons sur ce secteur qui est
très très important qui soit au niveau
de l'organisation qui soit au niveau de
ce dont on parle il faut absolument
comprendre que les personnes qui sont là
aujourd'hui
nécessitent une formation qui peut être
différente ou en tout cas qui
nécessitent une formation supplémentaire
pour les prendre en charge des gens des
personnes des femmes la plupart du temps
d'ailleurs le problème des personnes
injustes un problème de femme c'est nous
qui veut vendre plus longtemps il sait
des femmes qui s'occupent des femmes et
donc de ce point de vue là il faut
savoir aussi être présent et être
revendicatif ce que les femmes ne savent
pas vraiment faire on va faire une toute
petite parenthèse parce que évidemment
vous avez abordé le sujet le sujet c'est
le sujet salarial vous pouvez me
rappeler combien sont payés les
aides-soignants aujourd'hui dans le
public c'est un peu plus élevé
je crois qu'on est à 1005 et dans le
privé lucratif vous pouvez gagner en
dessous du SMIC ici arrive non mais
j'étais à le dire parce que moi j'ai des
profs de salaire à l'appui avant le
Ségur je précise avant les 187 euros du
CG de la santé
l'augmentation de 187 euros ils arrivent
à faire en sorte parce que vous avez un
contrat à 151 heures mais au mois de
février tout le monde gagne beaucoup
moins parce que vous explique que vous
n'avez pas fait 151 heures
qui avait cette exploit mais je préfère
le dire Corian c'est une que les gens
sachent quand ils payent beaucoup c'est
que ça va pas dans notre poche
des entreprises privées qui officient
dans le secteur on va voir un deuxième
extrait du documentaire j'irai tout de
suite après vous demander votre avis et
là on va parler des pathologies et du
changement de
personnes qui aujourd'hui vont dans les
EHPAD
le public qu'on accueille à l'heure
actuelle aussi et complètement différent
si je peux me permettre qu'il y a une ne
serait-ce qu'une dizaine d'années déjà
ils étaient beaucoup plus autonome c'est
quand qu'ils ne peuvent plus rester à la
maison donc quand dans avec des
pathologies ou peut-être plus
importantes et la maladie du siècle
l'Alzheimer
Monique Bora vous parliez tout à l'heure
de la formation des soignants
là on comprend mieux c'est-à-dire que
les personnes qui sont accueillies le
profil de ces personnes a changé vous le
confirmez avec des pathologies beaucoup
plus nombreuses qu'elle ne l'était
auparavant et ce qu'on n'est pas un peu
victime du fait aussi d'avoir et on
continue à le faire d'ailleurs et sans
doute à juste titre d'essayer de garder
nos aïeux le plus possible à leur
domicile c'est à dire qu'à un moment à
partir du moment où ils arrivent dans
les EHPAD
là ils sont perdus beaucoup beaucoup
d'autonomie et souffre de pathologie
importante et nombreuses ce qui
nécessite évidemment de soigner
davantage les soignants oui c'est vrai
les personnes arrivent de plus en plus
tard dans les EHPAD et de plus en plus
malade avec en effet multiple paletos
pathologies très souvent après c'est
vrai que la plupart des gens ont envie
de rester chez eux plus longtemps
possible donc ça peut se comprendre le
problème je pense que c'est un problème
en fait que les pas attirant ne donne
pas envie aux personnes d'y aller avant
que ce soit vraiment le dernier recours
et c'est bien ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui
parce que les potes c'est pas une maison
de retraite ça s'adresse déjà aux
personnes en perm maison de retraite
médicalisée en fait donc absolument
à destination des personnes qui sont
perdent d'autonomie mais donc il y a un
peu cet effet repoussoir aujourd'hui de
l'EHPAD
qui peut être alimenté en effet par ce
qui circule dans les médias etc mais la
question c'est aujourd'hui
comment est-ce qu'on veut vieillir ou
comment et avec quel moyen et le
problème est pourquoi les EHPAD
ne donne pas envie mais parce que pas
assez personnel parce qu'on peut pas
proposer à ces activités
aux résidents donc forcément en fait ça
reste le dernier recours et c'est ce qui
fait que
il y a pas assez de personnel et
d'autant plus que les résidents ont de
plus en plus de pathologies
sur ce qu'on vient de se dire
cette image qu'on a de les pattes aussi
forme de mourrois je ne sais pas si on
peut prononcer le mot mais mais oui
c'est un peu l'image parfois qu'on a une
image un peu collective de miroir de
personnes où il y aurait maltraitance
malveillance à l'intérieur de ces
établissements dans mon idéal l'image
qui s'est les EHPAD si on arrive à avoir
un projet de loi sur l'autonomie je
pense que je proposerai qu'on de changer
de nom cela la connotation est tellement
négative dès que vous dites le mot est
pas que on s'en sortira pas et que si on
met des moyens
imaginons qu'on suivent les 31
préconisations que nous proposons faut
plus que ça s'appelle EHPAD parce que
c'est connoté négativement et
sincèrement le virus mes enseignants
maison de vie parce que enfin un peu de
gaieté dans ce monde de brut
et quand on est allé au Pays-Bas ils ont
pas le problème du virage du
domiciliaire le maintien à domicile au
pays c'est 2%
mais il y a une offre il y a une offre
en face quand vous présentez à la
personne le super village dit village
Alzheimer ou les gens vivent dans une
maison où il y a 4 personnes dans la
maison où toute la ville vit dans cette
dans cette ville d'italimer mais les
gens demandent que ça d'y aller et pour
les soignants parce que c'est ça le plus
important nous on a besoin que les
résidents entre en bonne santé fin oui
en bonne santé qu'on connaisse leurs
habitudes moi si je m'occupe de Madame
machin pendant 8 ans et que je sais que
elle met à chaque fois que j'amène une
compote de poires elle me dit ah mais tu
sais bien Caroline que j'aime pas la
poire ah non j'ai jamais bu du lait j'ai
jamais aimé le lait mais quand cette
personne sera alitée au fond de son lit
je connais très ses besoins et je sais
que quand je verrai la compote de porc
arriver je sais même pas la peine que
j'essaie de lui donner elle la mangera
pas elle n'aime pas plutôt que de mettre
une croix pas faim oui oui simplement ce
que je veux dire aussi c'est que bon
aujourd'hui nous parlons des EHPAD
évidemment mais c'est qu'un élément dans
toute cette cette dans la société dans
laquelle nous vivons ou nous vivons de
plus en plus longtemps et tout le monde
souhaite évidemment nous comme d'autres
personnes de venir plus longtemps
possible en bonne santé ce qui nécessite
en effet au-delà au-delà de
l'organisation des EHPAD d'avoir une
vraie grande loi grand âge que nous
n'avons pas encore mais la vraie grande
loi grand âge alors ça fait un moment
qu'on nous en parle là
c'est pas de la mandature précédente et
c'est pas non plus la mandature
sous la présidence de François Hollande
tout le monde en parle depuis des années
pourquoi on y arrive pas on n'y arrive
pas pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que et ça il faut le
souligner aussi
c'est pas du tout de la faute des
soignants c'est pas forcément la faute
des gouvernements on pourra en parler
c'est aussi le regard que la société
nous avons nous en France sur les
personnes âgées et ça c'est très tenace
vous savez on peut changer les choses en
disant mais oui il faut augmenter le
taux d'encadrement on peut le faire il
suffit de l'argent on peut le faire
changer les mentalités et le regard que
nous avons quand nous sommes jeunes sur
ceux qui le sont moins en France si on
le compare avec des pays nordiques ou
même plus proche de nous l'Espagne pour
parler que de l'Espagne
le regard des personnes âgées dans la
famille n'a rien à voir avec ce que nous
avons nous donc il faut en tenir compte
aussi je voulais savoir ce que vous
pensiez de la disparité qu'on peut
observer sur le prix des EHPAD selon une
santé le tarif mensuel moyen s'établit à
3900 euros à Paris 3400 euros dans la
périphérie de Paris et puis alors si on
va dans le Cantal la Haute-Saône la
Meuse ce tarif est inférieur tarif
mensuel bien sûr à 1800 euros énorme
disparité et c'est à dire qu'on les
résidents n'ont pas le droit au même à
la même attention dans tous ces
établissements ou c'est simplement lié à
la situation de de ces établissements
soit en milieu urbain périurbain ou
rural
en effet qui joue dans le dans le tarif
que paye les résidents dans le tarif
hébergement après comme on disait tout à
l'heure
en fait ce qu'on paye ce que les
résidents payent ne garantit en rien la
qualité d'accompagnement très souvent un
prix élevé notamment dans en région
parisienne dans des villes assez
bourgeoises etc comme à Neuilly etc on
va payer tout ce qui est hôtellerie donc
ça veut dire peut-être des chambres plus
spacieuses etc mais on n'aura pas
forcément de plus de personnel en fait
et ce dont on besoin les résidents et
c'est le personnel parce qu'en fait on
peut avoir une très belle chambre si on
n'a personne pour s'occuper de soi pour
échanger pour vous accompagner aux
toilettes etc enfin en fait ça sert à
rien donc le noeud du problème il est il
est vraiment sur le le taux
d'encadrement il y a trois sources de
financement pour pour un EHPAD
aujourd'hui ou peut-être nous les
rappeler il y a le département le
département l'État et
la partie soin c'est elle est à la
partie hébergement c'est le département
et après les familles les familles la
Caisse d'Allocations Familiales c'est vu
qu'il y a une partie hébergement vous
avez le droit à une apl ou une
allocation d'autonomie mais alors ça
c'est pareil quoi si les gens pouvaient
la demander parce que le non recours est
assez est assez énorme est-ce que le
coup avec les chiffres que j'ai cité là
c'est disparité
et plus important en France que dans un
certain nombre d'autres pays européens
on va croire que j'ai des actions au
Pays-Bas je vous jure que non mais au
Pays-Bas c'est entre quand on avait fait
le rapport entre 0 et 2000 euros selon
nos revenus
et
j'invite tout le monde à aller voir
là-bas parce que c'est tellement voilà
donc si vous n'avez pas les moyens c'est
zéro et pour ceux qui ont les moyens
c'est 2000 euros par mois oui je pense
que la différence vient du fait aussi
que comme beaucoup de nos politiques
publiques ces politiques publiques sont
très marquées par une forte
dimension technocratique et que alors
que le financement dans les pays
nordiques ou ailleurs et relativement
simple il y a pas il y a pas trois
financeurs il y a que chez nous où il y
a aujourd'hui trois financeurs le
Conseil départemental ce que les gens
ignorent d'ailleurs la plupart du temps
le Conseil départemental puisqu'ils sont
en charge des départements de la
dépendance justement sur la dépendance
la sécurité sociale sur les soins et
l'hébergement donc les personnes âgées
mais quelle différence peut-on faire
entre le soin et la dépendance quand on
parle des personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
dans les EHPAD aucune et pourtant on a
toujours trois financeurs et ça c'est
une des réformes absolument une des
premières réformes mais vous imaginez
comme elle peut ne pas être simple une
des premières réformes qu'il faudrait
faire pour baisser le reste à charge des
personnes vous voyez qu'on a besoin
d'une réforme changement de modèle que
vous préconisez d'ailleurs toutes les
deux dans ce absolument dans ce rapport
alors vous priez souvent c'est vrai
comme référence les Pays-Bas qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui du suivi du
contrôle des établissements dont on
parle aujourd'hui les EHPAD a comparé
aux autres pays européens à l'évidence
il y a beaucoup d'autres pays dont les
Pays-Bas ou les contrôles sont plus
importants d'ailleurs on ne prévient pas
à des contrôles où sont des organismes
indépendants qui officient pour faire la
contrôle de ses établissements
aujourd'hui en France on a imposé un
contrôle tous les deux ans suite à cette
fameuse affaire ORPEA ça suffit est-ce
que les contrôles sont bien mis en place
dans notre pays qu'est-ce qui manque à
ces contrôles pour être plus efficient
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
renforcement des contrôles depuis
l'affaire européens
parce que les contrôles étaient vraiment
inexistant mais en tout cas n'avait
aucune utilité parce que souvent en
effet on prévenait à l'avance et quand
on se rendait sur place que j'ai vu
qu'on contrôlait aussi à distance sur
des fichiers Excel c'est un contrôle
très comptable finalement et le problème
après c'est sur un problème très humain
c'est toujours les moyens qu'on y met
donc il faut qu'il y ait plus de
contrôleurs mais finalement le problème
en fait c'est pas tant de contrôler
parce qu'on sait que il y a des
dysfonctionnements dans ces
établissements là public associatif ou
privé donc on a beaucoup contrôlé si on
sait on sait grâce à vous qui avez par
exemple enquêté pendant trois ans on
sait parce qu'il y a des lanceurs
d'alerte parfois dans les établissement
qui le disent enfin c'est pas nouveau en
fait l'affaire ORPEA enfin l'affaire des
fossoyeurs à
lancer une bombe comme vous le disiez
mais en même temps c'est des choses dont
on savait depuis des années qui était
répété qui était
voilà dites dans de multiples rapports
le titre de votre ces sons de maltraiter
nos vieux bon il est sorti avant le
livre de votre confrère c'est qu'en fait
les les différents contrôles ne vont
rien révéler de ce qu'on ne sait déjà et
le problème pour moi encore une fois
c'est plutôt de mettre des moyens pour
pour améliorer justement la prise en
charge l'accompagnement de des personnes
âgées aujourd'hui et donc plus que de
faire des contrôles je pense qu'on
devrait mettre plutôt l'argent
finalement pour mieux rémunérer le
personnel pour encourager les formations
etc parce que une chose dont on n'a pas
est-ce qu'on peut davantage conditionné
le financement public de ces
établissements
par exemple par rapport à au ratio
personnel soignants résident c'est à
dire
si si on fixe un ratio aussi les
respecter à ce moment-là l'aide publique
va aller à ces établissements si c'est
pas le cas on ne verse pas d'être public
ces établissements est-ce que c'est
possible ça oui ça peut être une bonne
solution a priori si
minimum est imposé que les
établissements qui ne le respectent pas
n'est pas de financement public ça tout
à fait alors un mot toutes les deux
avant la fin de cette émission sur le
contrôle
et comment on peut mieux contrôler les
choses et ce qu'il faut contrôler tous
les établissements et ce qu'il faut
faire contrôler ce dont on sait qu'il y
a une alerte
on ne peut contrôler que les règles
fixées là actuellement il y a plus
aucune règle fixée la maltraitance
institutionnelle est devenue un fait et
donc vous allez envoyer des gens
contrôler le niveau de la maltraitance
donc moi je dis mettons les moyens
fixons les règles ensemble et ensuite
contrôlons mais là contrôler
l'impensable je peux déjà vous dire les
résultats des contrôles ça va pas être
brillant oui ce que je voulais dire
c'est que dans le PLFSS là on a renforcé
en effet considérablement le contrôle la
seule chose moi ce que je pense c'est
personnel on peut pas vivre tout le
temps dans une société de contrôle il
faut intervenir en amont
parce que on sait qu'elle est la nature
de ces contrôles ensuite la nature de
ces dysfonctionnements et bien il y a un
problème de moyen mais pas seulement il
y a un problème en fait de définition de
la politique qu'on veut mener pour les
personnes âgées on n'est pas des
ailleurs nous ne l'avons pas encore mais
nous l'espérons
nationale certes relative mais elle va
peut-être pouvoir faire avancer les les
choses merci vraiment à toutes les trois
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui pour parler des EHPAD après
de notre documentaire intitulé prendre
soin vos réactions ce sera sur hashtag
débat doc sur Twitter merci à sel
massali qui comme à l'accoutumée à
préparer cette émission et rendez-vous
pour un prochain débat doc avec bien
entendu son documentaire et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]